charity is something I need to do I want
to impart the same love that God has
shown me to take care of a patient
itta Nobles me and it enables the
patient dr. alida ACK and her husband
John spend six hours a week volunteering
in a free health care clinic that they
started together in Somerset New Jersey
that's good it came down a little bit
we'll see people come in with sore
throats ear aches typical upper
respiratory infections they'll have
abdominal pain urinary tract infections
we diagnose many new cases of diabetes
people just find themself sick with no
money and no insurance and they're
terrified obviously think alike what
does Olivia that okay okay movie the
moral issue is that person in need
deserves care regardless of their
ability to pay some of the patients who
show up here aren't technically
uninsured they're covered by Medicaid
which is the government's insurance
program for the poor so why come to a
free clinic Medicaid recipients often
have a lot of trouble finding anyone who
will treat them because the program pays
doctors so little in fact eck only sees
Medicaid patients in her volunteer
clinic because she can't afford to treat
them in her private practice if you're
getting reimbursed 17 dollars for a
visit it won't be long before you have
to close your doors because you can't
pay your staff I'm not sure who gets
paid but somebody is getting all that
money and it's not those who actually
touched the patients a card that says
you have health insurance is not
healthcare avec Roy is a senior fellow
at the New York city-based think tank
the Manhattan Institute and he
specializes in health care policy all
too often people who claim to care for
the poor say I'm gonna give you this
card that says you have health insurance
my work is done you figure it out but
the hard work is actually making sure
that person gets treated for one thing
Medicaid recipients are more likely to
die of cancer because they can't see
doctors they get diagnosed later at a
stage of the disease where it's too late
and they can't be cured
that's the implication of a study
published in the Journal of the National
Cancer Institute which found that when
compared to the privately insured
Medicaid recipients were more likely to
have late stage cancer when first
diagnosed it's also difficult for
Medicaid patients to find qualified
surgeons who will treat them a
University of Virginia study found that
when Medicaid patients checked into the
hospital for surgery there were about
twice as likely as the privately insured
to die there even patients with no
insurance were more likely to make it
out of a hospital alive than Medicaid
recipients because President Obama and
much of Congress are concerned primarily
with the symbolism of providing all
Americans with health insurance Medicaid
is about to get a whole lot bigger
despite its failings our children
they're gonna grow up knowing that a man
named Barack Obama put the final girder
in the framework for a social network in
this country to provide the single most
important element of what people need
and that is access to good health
Obama care has made it so that millions
of people will be eligible to enroll for
Medicaid for the first time next year
but the Supreme Court ruled that states
don't have to participate in Obamacare
is Medicaid expansion so far the
governors of 19 states have come out
against expanding Medicaid even though
it means turning down federal money the
alternative is not to abandon the poor
the alternative is to allow the poor to
get the same high-quality health care
that most Americans enjoy through the
private insurance system so what's the
best way to accomplish that without
spending more money that we don't have
Roy says the federal government should
take all the money it devotes to the
program and simply give it to States so
they can experiment with health care
plans in which the patient's in control
and let them spend it on the doctor of
their choice or maybe you know what
maybe they're healthy and they'd rather
have a high deductible health insurance
plan with a health savings account some
people do want those things right you
know let people take them take the money
and get the bureaucrats out of the way
and you'll find suddenly that there's a
lot more efficiency in the way people
actually get health Care Act on the
other hand believes charity care could
be a big part of the solution if only
the government helped incentivize more
doctors to volunteer their time our idea
is to have the state cover us for
medical malpractice for our private
practices if we volunteer a certain
amount of time like four hours a week
every doctor I talk to says I would do
that in a heartbeat beca's worked with
New Jersey senator Robert singer who's
sponsored a bill that would put this
plan into effect in New Jersey and it's
currently waiting consideration by the
Senate's health care committee in the
meantime come next year when Obamacare
takes full effect
charitable clinics like hers will be
more essential than ever to pick up the
slack for social safety net that's just
not working I volunteer six hours a week
I've been doing it since 2003 so that's
nine years I honestly say I come away
each time feeling good that I was able
to make a difference